[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo
l'essentiel de l'actu politique et
parlementaire de la semaine
bonjour michael bonjour katia bonjour a
tous notre invité cette semaine et
christophe borgel bonjour bonjour le
député socialiste de haute-garonne et
vous avez beaucoup d'actualité en ce
moment parce que vous êtes président du
comité d'organisation de la primaire de
la gauche
on va en parler longuement dans un
instant mais d'abord on va dérouler le
fil de l'actualité de la semaine
oui dans la confiance accordée à bernard
cazeneuve le nouveau premier ministre a
fait son discours de politique générale
à l'assemblée il a promis que son bail
de 5 mois à matignon serait utile pour
l'avenir du pays
l'état d'urgence prolongé jusqu'au 15
juillet sénateurs et députés ont voté le
projet de loi c'est la cinquième
prolongation
et puis on ouvrira une séquence
politique qu'avec bien sur
l'organisation de la primaire à gauche
neuf candidats pour le moment dont une
femme le vote aura lieu les 22 et 29
janvier
alors vous le vivez l'image de la
semaine c'est le vote de confiance et le
discours de politique générale
[Musique]
les députés ont accordé une large
confiance au nouveau premier ministre
bernard cazeneuve écouter sur
l'intervention je reviens juste après je
vous propose loup consacrée aux grandes
causes et il en est pas de plus grande
que de servir notre pays
voilà et dans ce discours de trois
quarts d'heure environ bernard cazeneuve
a expliqué comment il comptait occuper
ces cinq mois à matignon il a aussi
notamment prôné le respect en politique
écoutez cette séquence au coeur de mon
action la notion de respect le respect
qui proscrit le cynisme qui proscrit le
mensonge qui proscrit les postures qui
proscrit la violence qui proscrit les
outrances l'engagement que je prends
devant vous c'est d'être à chaque
instant dans le respect de l'opposition
de ne jamais chercher les vaines
querelles de ne jamais de ne jamais
convoqué les basses polémiques et d'être
dans un comportement qui réhausse la
politique parce que les français qui
louvoie sont aussi des français qui nous
vulve et les députés ont donc accordé la
confiance à bernard cazeneuve par 305
voix pour et 2 139 contre christophe
borgel s'est beaucoup c'est une
confiance plus large que celle accordée
à l'époque à manuel valls
ça veut dire quoi que la majorité
rassemblée autour de bernard cazeneuve
entretient un climat nouveau
il ya un climat nouveau qui vient aussi
de ce que dit l'opposition de ce qu'elle
veut faire pour la france
jamais on n'a eu depuis la profession
alors je sais pas si on doit dire merci
à l'opposition parce que pour le moment
dans les sondages est allée en situation
de l'emporter mais jamais jamais depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale on a eu un
candidat de la droite dans ce pays qui
s'est avancée avec un programme qui
remettait en cause les faits mais je
crois qu'il y à ce climat la city qui
impacte sur la gauche
et puis on a eu un discours d'un premier
ministre qui tint et premiers ministres
qui étaient extrêmement appréciée comme
ministre de l'intérieur qui a trouvé des
mots vous avez monté cette très belle
séquence sur le respect et puis enfin on
a un vote de confiance qui intervient à
un moment donné ou un stand de débats
qui ont pu opposer la gauche sont
quelque part dépassé par les résultats
donc il ya une ambiance de rassemblement
quand même vous l'avez senti dans
l'hémicycle et elle était là ou si elle
était là elle était là on l'a vu
avec les applaudissements des passés par
là ça veut dire que tout ce qui a été
fait jusqu'à présent et à l'ouvrir et
flore de nationalité la loi travail tout
ça c'est le passé
non je dis pas ça je dis que le grand
débat qui a opposé les uns et les autres
c'est le débat sur la faune de
l'économique
mais aujourd'hui même si c'est pas assez
et même en annonçant une croissance plus
faible que prévu
l'insee continue à annoncer que le
chômage va continuer à reculer
c'est pas assez il faut continuer à se
battre mais malgré tout tout ça crée une
ambiance
et puis une fois de plus j'ai dizier
merci l'opposition oui devant ce qui
peut arriver
chacun a conscience que vous allez
présentant les deux divisions mais si
tout était si bien que ça si le bilan
aussi pour alors pourquoi est ce que
françois hollande n'y est pas allé et
j'ai dit si tout était si bien que ça je
crois pas avoir dit que tout était si
bien que ça vous me posez une question
sur les raisons d'une confiance
largement acquise au premier ministre et
au nouveau gouvernement
il faut avoir un regard lucide sur le
bilan le paradoxe du jugement des
français sur le bilan c'est quand vous
leur demandez un jugement global il le
balaye d'un revers de main mais si vous
le traitez sujet par sujet ils partagent
bien souvent les mesures qui ont été
arrêtés alors cette petite question en
passant comme ça à christophe borgel
puisqu'on parle de premier ministre
l'ex-premier ministre manuel valls veut
supprimer le recours à l'article 49 3
qui permet au gouvernement de faire
passer un texte sans vote
est ce que c'est une bonne idée ou c'est
un coup de bluff même une provocation
lui qui l'a utilisé souvent j'ai mon
rôle c'est d'organiser la primaire donc
là donc je vais pas juger mais né sur
l'île
sur le fond mais je vais oui mais si je
commence à commenter chaque position des
uns et des autres mais par contre je
suis assez étonné de la manière dont la
presse a commenté
au delà du fond mais cette idée que si
on a fait quelque chose en gouvernant on
ne peut pas avoir regard sur son action
avec une scène
lucidité qui permet d'en tirer des
conclusions et célèbre virage à 180
degrés est
soyons francs j'ai pas l'impression en
l'occurrence que je crois que ce qui a
été exprimé hier c'est quelque chose que
de nombreux députés socialistes ont
déposé dans un amendement il ya un
moment dans le débat parlementaire à
l'époque où la droite était au pouvoir
cette idée qu'on restreignait le 49-3
aux questions budgétaires mais il ya eu
pas simplement le débat sur le 49-3 dans
le débat sur la démocratie
on a vu la demande de nos concitoyens de
participation on a vu les difficultés
sur un stand de projets locaux on voit
bien que le processus démocratique
d'élaboration de toute une série de
sujets dans notre société ne répond pas
à la demande de participation et être
changé c'est là dedans j'ai l'impression
que le candidat valls inscrit ses
propositions mais peut pas constater que
bien au delà du rejet de la loi travail
les français jugent que l'utilisation de
cet article 49 3 et hors du temps
démocratique
qu'appelle la volonté de participer et
dire quand un candidat dit page
enregistre sa avant j'avais des
propositions mauvais procès c'est ce que
vous dites quelque part au delà du
jugement est ce qu'il faut le faire ou
pas oui quand même
mais vous savez on a l'habitude on dit
blanc la presse tout dit pourquoi vous
dites pas noir ont dit de pouvoir la
presse tout dit pourquoi vous dites pas
blanc elle remplacée sur un autre sujet
on va voir quelle couleur
l'état d'urgence qui est sera en vigueur
en france jusqu'au 15 juillet au moins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
députés et sénateurs ont donc prolongé
l'ont donc voter le projet de loi qui
prolonge cet état d'exception permettant
perquisitions et assignation à résidence
compte rendu de séance avec françois
chevret l'assemblée nationale a adopté
c'est tard dans la nuit que les députés
ont voté la cinquième prorogation de
l'état d'urgence depuis les attentats du
13 novembre 2015
un état d'urgence devenue caduque avec
la démission du premier ministre manuel
valls pour empêcher les attaques
terroristes
il est prolongé jusqu'au 15 juillet
prochain la date n'est pas choisie au
hasard
ils peuvent s'attaquer à ce que sont
l'organisation des élections qui rythme
la vie démocratique de notre
démocratique de notre république et à ce
troisième titre
nous ne devons absolument pas baisser la
garde
pour les opposants à l'état d'urgence
l'argument ne tient pas en quoi ces
réunions ces rassemblements concentre
t'il plus de danger qu'une rame de métro
bondée une exposition de musée ou un
marché le dimanche matin
cette disposition contenue dans
l'article 3 ne traduit qu'une chose vous
ne savez pas comment arrêter cet état
d'urgence
c'est une machine infernale qu'il est
impossible d'arrêter les républicains
ont voté pour l'état d'urgence mais il
reproche au gouvernement un certain
manque d'ambition
vous devez vous interroger sur la
pertinence d'un cinquième renouvellement
mais mettre en oeuvre à la place une
véritable législation antiterroriste de
droit comme en somme un état d'autres
sécurité le texte est arrivé au sénat ce
matin s'il est adopté la france
connaîtra 20 mois d'état d'urgence
consécutif un record depuis la création
de ce régime d'exception lors de la
guerre d'algérie
voilà vote assez large à l'assemblée sur
ce sur ce projet de loi et les sénateurs
aussi l'ont votée c'est assez rare on a
envie de dire
est ce que ça ne pourrait pas arriver
plus souvent sur des textes
oui monsieur je pense que c'est dans la
réflexion qu'on évoquait sur la
démocratie
il ya une réflexion à avoir sur le
fonctionnement de notre parlement
on a un mode de scrutin qui conduit
jusqu'à présent on verra dans la
nouvelle réalité tripartite de la ville
politique gauche droite extrême droite
ce qu'il en est mais on a un mode de
scrutin qui concourent à des majorités
naître d'un camp et donc qui concourent
plutôt à des bloc contre bloc opposition
c'est pas le cas il ya des tas de pays
j'étais récemment en mission
parlementaire au danemark on voit que ça
fonctionne en allemagne autrement en
allemagne où le mode de scrutin conduit
souvent à l'obligation de trouver des
majorités mais il ya une vraie réflexion
à avoir sur ces aspects là oui bien sûr
sur le fond de ce texte sur l'état
d'urgence a l'impression que cette
finale on devenir votre automatique vous
avez eu cette impression là aussi fait
trop de monde ce que le parlement vote
et ça s'est fait dans l'express et vous
l'avez dit de toute façon assez large
pas d'automaticité sais pas si on peut
dire qu'il ne te met ici d une
conviction de la majorité assez large
des parlementaires que vu la menace
terroriste
on ne peut pas lever le pied on peut pas
lever la garde
il faut donner des garanties par rapport
à l'état de droit et c'est la logique du
gouvernement les dents l'état d'urgence
on n'est pas dans la création d'un état
d'exception de permanente avec ce que
certains appellent d'une intervention de
ceux ci les flots par exemple bûche
penser à celle de monsieur goujon
joselois de haute sécurité
non il ya besoin de deux mesures
particulières dans un moment tout à fait
que c'est la préparation de la sortie de
l'état d'urgence là je prends l'exemple
de ce que disait cécile duflot c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut peut-être
anticipé aussi oui mais souvenez-vous
après l'attentât de nice le président de
la république avait indiqué que préparer
la sortie et et tout le monde est tombé
dessus en disant quelle légèreté d'abord
annonçait la sortie alors qu'on vient
d'avoir un attentat à tout moment à tout
moment ça peut se hâtent ou moment ça
peut se produire ça pourrait durer des
années en fait et je sais pas si
personne ne servez les députés ont
montré leur leur désarroi en disant
notamment chez les verts pendant le
débat parlementaire personne ne sait
comment sortir concrètement de cet état
d'urgence
mais attendez par moments on entend
certains collègues j'ai l'impression que
l'état d'urgence c'est l'état de nom
berthet vous et moi je sais pas comment
vous circulez moi je prends le métro
quand je viens de mon domicile francine
hier à l'assemblée nationale où quand je
vais à toulouse
dans ma circonscription circulent
souvent transports en commun j'ai pas
l'impression d'être dans un pays en état
de guerre ou et où les libertés sont
bafouées donc et on a besoin par moments
dans la bataille contre le terrorisme
d'aller vite les plus de moyens on
donner plus de moyens de donner plus de
facilité ce qui ne veut pas dire le fait
de rogner les libertés de l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens avec octobre janot va
ouvrir une page politique primaires à
gauche
même si l'actualité à droite et vous
prenez tout à l'heure de françois fillon
vous allez pouvoir à nouveau parler de
ses propositions notamment en matière de
santé et son projet sur la sécurité
sociale regardez ce reportage et puis
évidemment vous posera quelques
questions après françois fillon n'en
finit plus de s'expliquer sur son projet
pour la santé dans une tribune du figaro
devant les députés et les sénateurs
et hier lors d'une visite d'un hôpital
des hauts-de-seine le candidat à la
présidentielle répète à aucun moment je
n'ai voulu privatiser l'assurance
maladie plus question de distinguer
entre gros risques de santé couvertes
par l'assurance maladie et petit risque
de santé laisser aux mutuelles et aux
complémentaires comme il l'annoncé lors
de la primaire ces soutiens parle d'un
exercice de clarification nécessaire
mais une question demeure comment
françois fillon compte atteindre les 20
milliards d'euros d'économies sur les
dépenses de santé que prévoit son
programme les leviers ne sont pas
nombreux la baisse des moyens des
hôpitaux ou une baisse du remboursement
des soins
aucune réponse pour le moment françois
fillon annonce une convention pour
préciser le projet je vais donc
continuer dans les prochaines semaines
mes rencontres avec tous les
professionnels pour les écouter et
j'organiserai ensuite avec mes amis
parlementaires dont beaucoup sont ici et
l'avez compris sont des médecins d une
convention qui nous permettra de
préciser ce projet en étroite
concertation avec les professionnels de
la santé de tous les secteurs
en attendant le discours du candidat met
l'accent sur l'état des finances
publiques
ils comptent mandaté des experts
indépendants pour réaliser un audit des
comptes sociaux bas 14 borgel françois
fillon essayent de clarifier un petit
peu sa position sur la sécurité sociale
sur la santé sur son programme pour vous
c'est quoi recula rétropédalage ou prise
de conscience que ce qu'il avance sur le
programme est difficilement applicable
en l'état
j'ai vu aucune prise de conscience parce
qu'il est toujours un objectif qui
d'abord est incompréhensible
il faut faire 20 milliards d'économies
sur l'assurance maladie alors que
l'instance indépendante qui juge les
comptes de la sécurité sociale nous dit
que il ya longtemps qu'ils sont pas
portés comme ça et qu'on est en train de
retrouver l'équilibré et que quand on se
projette dans l'avenir
ça va même aller en s'améliorant encore
mais quel est l'objet les gérants on est
dans cette espèce de dogmatisme qui
n'ont pas des économies pour trouver une
bonne gestion de nos finances publiques
mais des économies par une espèce de
dogmatisme le même sujet que quand on
évoque cinq cent mille suppressions de
postes de fonctionnaires
c'est une espèce de dogme vis-à-vis de
tout ce qui fait la solidarité on sent
que j'ignorais dogmatique c'est ce que
vous êtes tout
oui je pense que là on n'ait vraiment
avec une droite qui à cette espèce de
domme vis-à-vis de tout ce qui est
l'action publique c'est quoi cette dogme
si vous pouvez le définir alors c'est
quoi c'est une privatisation futurs
programmes et de la sécurité sociale
mais enfin mais sinon c'est pas
compliqué le journaliste qui commentait
très clair vous voulez faire 20
milliards d'économies il n'y a pas 36
manières de les faire soit vous
déremboursés soit vous baisser ce qui va
vers l'hopital public dont il est donc
on voit bien que ce que la droite avait
déjà fait à travers les franchises
médicales
est ce qu'il y a en filigrane dans la
primaire pour la gagner françois fillon
s'est dévoilée maintenant dans la
présidentielle parce que ça va lui poser
un problème
il veut avancer masqué beaucoup plus
qu'une clarification le sentiment que ça
me donne c'est qu'on essaie d'avancer
masqué sur ce sujet là mais la vérité
simple et quand son porte parole
va sur une antenne pour s'expliquer il
nous explique que c'est en fonction de
l'intensité du rhume qu'on va être
remboursée et donc on voit bien que ce
qui pointe derrière c'est un moindre
remboursement pour la protection de nos
concitoyens parce qu'on a tort de dire
la vérité du fond du projet c'est ça que
vous dites aux français ah ben je crois
qu'il ya bien un sujet sur lequel les
français n'accepteront jamais qu'on
abaisse leur protection
c'est celui de la santé c'est clair et
on va parler de votre actualité puisque
à gauche jeudi 15 décembre était jour de
clôture pour les candidatures à la
primaire de la gauche ils sont neuf à
avoir déposé leur candidature à la belle
alliance populaire est allé lui avec
françois goulard dernier arrivé et seule
femme en lice
sylvia pinel du parti radical de gauche
ministre de françois hollande pendant
près de quatre ans elle veut incarner le
renouvellement
vincent peillon ancien ministre de
l'éducation de françois hollande de 2012
à 2014 défend le bilan du président de
la république mais prend malgré tout ses
distances dans les cinq ans de bonnes
choses ont été faites et en même temps
j'ai déjà dit je crois assez nettement à
plusieurs reprises qu'elle me semblaient
être les difficultés de ce quinquennat
parce que la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes y compris la situation qui a
conduit le président de la république à
ne pas pouvoir se représenter c'est bien
qu'il y avait des problèmes
l'ancien ministre de la
rieur puis premier ministre manuel valls
dans la course
suite au retrait de françois hollande se
veut le continuateur de la ligne
politique du chef de l'état si je suis
candidat à la présidence de la
république
après le choix qui a été celui de
françois hollande c'est parce que je
pense que je suis capable d'incarner la
france dans ce monde d'aujourd'hui d'un
quart des lots valeur et d'internés
confort une généreuse
al'inverse arnaud montebourg ancien
ministre de l'économie qui ne cesse de
critiquer l'action du gouvernement
depuis qu'il l'a quitté en 2014 espère
renouveler la donne politique à gauche
c'est l'air du grand large qui
s'engouffre dans les partis qui les
bouscule lorsqu'ils veulent imposer leur
candidature leurs projets leurs
éléphants leur dinosaure
libérons-nous des figures et des visages
imposer des stratégies diviseuse des
appareils en par omis de la primaire
comme on se saisit de sa propre liberté
autres ministres démissionnaires benoît
hamon veut réduire le temps de travail
mettre en place un revenu universel et
supprimer la loi elle conneries gérard
filoche
issu de l'ailé gauche du ps souhaite
revaloriser le smic à 1800 euros et
plafonner les hauts salaires françois de
rugy du parti écologiste et jean luc
bennahmias de l'union des démocrates et
écologistes sont également dans la
course
les organisateurs de la primaire espère
mobiliser entre un million et demi et
deux millions d'électeurs lors des deux
tours prévus les 22 et 29 janvier
prochain arrêt sauf borgel on va revenir
un peu plus longuement sur ces primaires
mais d'abord de question très politique
d'abord sur sûr ça vous avez vu le
climat les accusations des uns et des
autres sur les cotisations et c'est ce
que vous dites aujourd'hui
halte au feu j'ai dit surtout à partir
de demain
thomas clay le président de la haute
autorité va annoncer la liste des
candidats qui ont rempli les conditions
de candidature vous souvenez pour la
primaire de la droite ya eu un décalage
entre ce qu'ils ont déposés et ceux dont
on a constaté qu'effectivement il avait
les parrainages monsieur mariton qui
d'ailleurs elle avait accepté à retenir
comme le son fond la haute autorité à
droite a dit monsieur mariton pop
être candidat il n'y avait pas eu de
commentaires d accepter les règles mais
et donc demain il y aura les candidats
il faut passer au débat des propositions
parce que on a vu un peu de polémique
sur des histoires de cotisation et
d'autre mais on a déjà un débat des
propositions on évoquait au début de
convention celle de l'ancien premier
ministre manuel valls mais au cours de
son meeting benoît hamon on l'a fait et
donc tout ça voyez un climat cet accord
qui va qui est plutôt mal ça est ce que
vous dites aujourd'hui maintenant ça
suffit à rien un crime mais attendez il
ya un climat à gauche qui est un climat
de division
celui qui vient vous dire l' inverse sur
un plateau fait la langue de bois ce
climat division il peut conduire la
gauche être éliminé c'est pour ça qu'on
fait une primaire et si c'est la
primaire des chicaya et bien elle sera
un échec
les gens ne viendront pas voter si c'est
la primaire des propositions tourner
vers l'avenir avec un débat loyal
normale sur ce que nous avons fait
pendant cinq ans au gouvernement
alors j'en suis convaincu les femmes et
les hommes de gauche seront au rendez
vous de la fin janvier comme ceux de
droite ont été au rendez vous de la fin
de ceux de droite peuvent être aussi les
bienvenus à cette primaire pour voter
des candidates et pour voter il faut
être des vecteurs et souscrire à un
engagement
voilà sur les valeurs de la gauche et
des écologistes à pendre à l'issue des
gens de droite devient fou je le répète
et puis je vais vous dire là encore sans
langue de bois j'ai passé mon temps à
dire que les gens de gauche je n'irai
pas voter et je me suis totalement
trompés parce que je pensais qu'il y en
aurait 2 ou 3% et y en a eu visiblement
entre 12 et 15% mais je continue à
garder un raisonnement simple quand on
partage les valeurs de la droite on va
logiquement voter à la primaire de la
droite quand on partage les valeurs de
la gauche on va logiquement voter à la
primaire de la gauche donc de réparer
sache mon chez eux
mais je dis qu'il ya une logique du mois
je me vois pas signer quelque chose
disant que je partage les valeurs de la
droite alors que suis de gauche je suis
une question vous croyez de chicaya tout
à l'heure si cette primaire devient de
1ère d chicaya ne pourra pas rassembler
66 % des français pensent aujourd'hui
qu'il est impossible de rassembler en
tout cas pour le prochain celui qui
sortira de cette primaire qui est
impossible de rassembler entre jusqu'à
mélenchon et macro que c'est mission
impossible
non je crois pas je comprend un volet
est sorti dans libération je comprends
je connais sondage de viavoice publiée
par libération
comment voulez-vous quand on voit
l'image avec des candidats déjà déclarés
qui disent moi je moi je suis le
renouveau de la vie politique
moi je suis la vraie gauche radicale
mais j'ai envie de leur dire moi je moi
je
toi tu es éliminé comme tout le monde
alors peut-être qu'il y en a qui se
gargarise d'être les premiers des
éliminés mais la belle affaire si à la
fin les hommes qui croient dans un
chemin progressistes pour la france les
hommes et les femmes qui croient à sa
non comme choix au second tour contre
fillon et marine le pen
jim jara c est avec nous c'est notre
partenaire du figaro il va vous
interroger à nouveau sur la primaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui jean michaël blanc katia
bonjour christophe borgel
bonjour vous l'avais dit la liste
définitive des candidats sera annoncée
samedi vous souhaitiez vous christophe
borgel uniquement sept candidats qui
trouvent que neuf candidats ont déposé
leurs parrainages vendredi est ce que ça
veut dire que deux candidats vont être
exclu lundi c'est la décision de savoir
qui est candidat appartient la haute
autorité et je me suis fixé une règle
chaque fois que la haute autorité nous
demande d'aller dans un sens ou dans un
autre dans un primaire je suis leur avis
et donc ils décideront librement la lie
moi j'ai fait une remarque purement
regard des débats de la droite je me
suis dit au delà de cette ça va être
compliqué s'il ya huit candidats qui
remplissent les conditions pour la thur
à huit candidats et au soleil aura
échoué il faut qu'ils acceptent le
résultat
écoutez je préside le comité national
vers quel qu'il soit maire je suis à la
8ème résolution de la haute autorité
je les ai toutes appliquées sans rien
dire donc ce que je suis capable de
faire c'est à dire accepter l'avis de
cette haute autorité qui nous avons mis
en place qui est une autorité
indépendante c'est thomas clay qui a
qu'il a reconstitué pour cette primaire
on l'a mis en place parce qu'on a besoin
d'avoir une espèce de gardiens de la
paix de cette primaire qui juge de son
éthique qui juge de son ambiance et qui
décide un mauvais parti rempli les
conditions pour être candidat mais qui
va valider les résultats et donc moi
j'accepte les avis de la haute autorité
la suggère à tout le monde lors du
candidat gérard filoche 10 sur toutes
les antennes que la direction du ps fait
tout pour l'empêcher d'être candidat
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez que la
haute autorité nous a demandé de faire
connaître la candidature de gérard
filoche acquis et socialiste n'a
l'ensemble des membres du conseil
national du parti socialiste pour qu'il
puisse demander leur parrainage nous
l'avons fait immédiatement après que la
haute autorité
nous les demander la haute autorité
entre les mains les parrainages qui a
déposé gérard filoche soit il a les
parrainages suffisants dans l'une des
quatre catégories dans lequel il fallait
les avoir
les membres de notre
c'est nationale les parlementaires les
maires de villes de plus de 10 mille ou
les conseillers départementaux et
régionaux soit il ne les a pas mais
c'est à la haute autorité de nous le
dire il a mauvaise presse auprès de la
direction du ps on seconde ses propos
sur le patron de total christophe de
margerie qui est décédé il avait
qualifié de très de suceurs de sang le
jour de son décès il y avait une
procédure de sanction qui avait été
lancée ce jour là rien ne s'est passé de
pluie est ce que sont des vins son
éventuelle sortie de la primaire ce
serait justement la sanction non non non
non cet événement taille il faut pas
mélanger les choses
vous auriez pu ces deux généraux
puisqu'ils y avait le patron de total
payé vu il ya eu un commentaire tout à
fait sympathique sur un accident car en
gironde sur le fait que c'était l'écart
macron qui était encore plus choquant
que le patron de total mais il sait le
disqualifie nan c'est pas l'objet on n'a
pas pris de mesures il ya des règles
d'organisation de la primaire
elles sont les mêmes pour tout le monde
et je ne doute pas une seule seconde que
soit il a effectivement les parrainages
et sa candidature sera validée soit elle
ne l'est pas et ça voudra dire tout
simplement qu'il a déposé un dossier où
il n'y avait pas les parrainages
d'accord trois débats vont être
organisées en l'espace de sept jours en
janvier ce que c'est pas trop la droite
avait fait la même chose mais en un mois
est ce que vous craignez pas de saturer
l'espace
alors quand quant à un moment donné on
évoquait un ou deux débats les
journalistes pas vous puisque on en a
parlé ensemble nous disait mais enfin
comment il ya des médias qui vont être
exclue des débats
mais comment vous allez en faire rue de
alors que vivent là je parle des
français je vous réponds oui mais c'est
vous qui posez la question pour le
moment vous n'avez pas un sondage et où
les français vous disent trois débats
c'est beaucoup trop
donc il y à des médias différents et
l'attendait de voir l'audience que je
constate vous savez c'est que l'audience
de ces débats de primaires que ce soit
la note de 2011 ou celle de la droite en
novembre fait plus de gens devant les
postes de télévision que toutes les
émissions politiques que les rédactions
invente moins d'une minute question le
ps va annoncer demain c'est la majorité
de ces investitures pour
législatives qu'en est il des soutiens
de daemen une macro je pense notamment à
richard ferrand qui savent caster ils
ont été investis par les militants dans
leur circonscription
est-ce que leur candidature va être
validée par le parti c'est la convention
nationale de demain qui le dira mais il
n'y a pas de raison que ce soit pas le
cas
il est chose sont claires et puis c'est
aussi embrassé déjà publiques
tous les candidats qui ont l'investiture
ont reçu une lettre leur rappelant ce
que ça voulait dire être investie par le
parti socialiste
ça veut dire qu'après la primaire quand
nous aurons notre candidate ou candidat
qui est celui qui gagnera la primaire
ceux qui sont investis par le parti
socialiste devront soutenir ce candidat
pour être clair et pas langue de bois
une fois plus que ceux qui le
soutiennent pas ne seront plus investie
par le parti socialiste
eh bien ce sera le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup christophe bilger les règles
sont claires donc merci à tous
[Musique]
qui